whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a Sim at the house in
Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
[Music]
thank you
how are you guys doing I came across a
video of some self-proclaimed liberal
Muslims talking about reinterpretation
of the Quran let's take a look at this
clip and come back and comment on this
clip the Quran must be re-interpreted
for the 21st century you always need to
reinterpret the Quran um whoever is
looking at the Quran whoever is reading
it needs to interpret it needs to
understand what Allah is telling that
person all the information everything
that we're learning is about getting us
closer to a just future and in the time
of the Prophet slavery was well and
Alive the Quran never outright abolished
slavery but people through their
interpretation decided that the Quran is
leading us to a future where slavery
shouldn't be allowed because it's unjust
yeah I agree I think the chronic attacks
is a holy text that should never be
changed or obviously written like that's
that's off the table but I think
interpretation kind of we talked about
the whole time matters but I've
consulted with different like mosque
leaders different people who actually
study Islam and not once it was like a
big overlap because they have their own
interpretation what the Quran is into
the modern world so I just think in
general there definitely should be a
more modern interpretation I think
what's going on here quite frankly is
that and this is the case with a lot of
Muslims in the west that they feel
pressured and maybe understandably so
because we're living in an age where the
dominant ethic of the world is the
liberal ethics not of the world I should
say I'm really the Western World and
being positioned in the western world as
Muslims is very difficult to escape the
claws of this ideology however what I
will say is this in fact
um really and truly you have to look at
liberalism as another religion it's
another religion in so much as it's a
transcendental idea with a set of
presuppositions which form their own
kind of morality and this in fact uh is
how some people like Charles Taylor and
other sociologists Define religion
itself
the example they gave though on the in
the video is not something which is as
controversial as one may think
it would be for example uh in the the
issue of slavery anyway Islamic slavery
which has nothing to do with the kind of
atrocious uh race-based transatlantic
slavery abuse that the Western white man
conducted for 400 years or older than
that in the transatlantic region not
we've got nothing to do with that so I
think first and foremost saying that
well the Quran allowed it but it didn't
allow that kind of slavery and that
needs to be very very clear because
quite frankly in the imagination of the
westerners this is when someone's a
slavery you imagine an innocent black
man being whipped or lynched or hurt and
racially abused now Islam does not and
has never allowed that kind of slavery
in fact there is a specific kind of
slavery which only we would say we are
allowed to have with Allah which is the
ultimate and unconditional obedience for
the prophet sallallahu alaihi told us
there is no obedience to the creation in
the Disobedience to the Creator so this
ultimate kind of slavery only exists
with Allah
with God Almighty as for indentured
servitude or selling and buying of
course this existed at the time of the
prophet and they're right to mention
that this was not something which was
abolished outright however well soles or
people who are Jewish Prudential experts
even before the formulation of
liberalism itself as a religion as an
ideology as a political ideology a
political philosophy
they made the same point as these
liberal Muslims are making which are
which is effectively that Islam is
attempting to move in the direction of
the abolition of slavery and of course
one of the eight categories of zakat is
for the freeing of slavery as is
mentioned
it's not the place or time to speak
about slavery here in great depth but
the point is the point they were making
was not specific or it's not um you
don't require to reinterpret the Quran
through liberalism in order to make this
point you could make the same point
which is that Islam effectively has an
emancipatory discourse as we would know
already if you read the total ballad and
just are memos of the people in chapter
91 and what I have memorized this
chapter young people in the Muslim World
um
is the good way freeing slaves is the
good way so in other words if one is
saying that because this seems to be the
thrust of the argument that in order for
us to do away with slavery we have to
embrace a new morality no because quite
frankly the Islamic or the quranic
message from the very beginning had a
very clear emancipatory discourse the
kind of so-called slavery that existed
then is nothing like what we're what
we're used to or you know in the West an
imagination or with racial slavery or
racism in general which is completely
outlawed in Islam you see because Islam
is the only ancient religion
that I know of which clearly
Outlaws racism
it's not in the Old Testament there's
not one verse in the Old Testament or in
the talmud or anything like that which
Outlaws racism effect to the contrary
there is you know this preferential
treatment that we're getting from the
tribe of Israel who God had to repent to
and lost to a wrestling match to the one
of the protagonists of and so on
Jacob no Islam as the the prophet told
us there is no superiority over a black
man over a white man or a white man or a
black man or an arable for a non-arab or
non-arable and Arab so I think it's very
important to make these points clear the
kind of slavery that people are talking
about which is morally uh totally
unacceptable is something that Islam had
nothing to do with in any time and the
prophet of Islam is completely absolved
from and the Quran is completely
absolved from we don't need the white
man who himself himself the white man
the liberal white man I'm not talking
about the color of your skin because
I've just said we don't believe in
racism we're talking about the
archetypal liberal white man
yes we don't need him to tell us what
morality is we don't need liberalism to
tell us that in fact we need you oh
liberalism you know torch bearers of
liberalism in order to know that slavery
is wrong because quite frankly slavery
coexisted with liberalism
think about when in America as a country
I think that woman was talking from when
it was outlawed as a constitutional
amendment I think the 13th Amendment in
America was in 1861 to 1865 when the
Civil War happened and as a result of it
slavery was outlawed but we know that
the founding fathers of America were
really
some of the main figures of liberalism
and all of them if not had slaves
themselves allowed it to happen
as you many of you will know that so
there's nothing intrinsic about
liberalism as an ideology
which for example to use this uh slavery
example that they gave without law or
without even Outlaw racism we know that
racism was something which existed uh in
fact justification was given uh Colonial
justification for racism even scientific
type Colonial justification so
this is a non-starter you have given us
no reason to switch Paradigm you've
given us no reason to go to liberalism
you have given us even your example was
a false example and unfortunately
unfortunately this is the pressure that
some people
you know have you know quite frankly in
the Muslim world have to go through but
because they came across very humbly I
don't want to put these people off I'll
say to this this lady young lady and to
the man uh
I'm saying to come back to
traditionalism come back to Quran come
back to the Sunnah come back to the
acquire of the salaf of the sayings of
the people of old come back to the
tradition come back because our
tradition as is not as rigid as you
think it is even the traditional
understanding of Islam is not as rigid
as you think it is I mentioned very
famously he said
if the situation gets very constrained
then the Sharia becomes very flexible
the opposite is true
when the situation becomes very flexible
then the share becomes more strict so we
have an inbuilt flexibility without the
within the credit scores this was
something understood with the early
people remember Shafi being one of them
so you don't need
you know white Colonial discourses or
dominant paradigms of the West in order
to really come to these conclusions we
don't need any anything outside of our
guidance you know
of the Quran Sunnah and hopefully this
convinces
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even more